the world's first deepwater webcam was
installed in Monterey Bay wired went out
with a team of marine biologists as a
robotic submarine called the Ventana
dropped the eye in the sea web cam into
the water the remote monitoring system
will take video in various scientific
readings 24 hours a day sending them via
the Monterey Bay Aquarium Research
Institute's new undersea data network
the Monterey accelerated research system
also known as Mars the researchers don't
know exactly what they're going to find
but the homie despot never-before-seen
underwater creatures that just happened
to float by usually in order to
photograph sea creatures humans take man
- robotic submarines into the depths
pouring bright light into the ocean the
new camera hover uses specially tuned
red light which most of the organisms
that that depth can't see they just see
dark but we can see them when we arrived
at the dock in Moss Landing south of San
Francisco it was still dark but the bay
was waking up the expedition left on the
Point Lobos research vessel which was
famous for making everyone ill at 7 a.m.
just as the Sun rose the crew put the
Ventana the robotic submarine through
its paces on the deck the trickiest part
was ballasting the sub properly to carry
the way of the eye of the sea they
wanted a slow steady descent the sub is
lowered into and out of the water with a
crane to delicate operation as the ocean
Bob's up and down and they try not to
bang the submarine against the side of
the boat when the submarine went into
the water
a group of curious dolphins investigated
it swimming around the sub and peering
into its cameras after the submarine was
in the water the scientists connected
the eye and the sea camera to it and
launched it overboard as well the
control room on the point lobos is full
of monitors displaying the live video
feed from the subs camera as they
lowered into the deep they pointed the
camera straight down so they could keep
an eye on the camera that was slowly
dropping to the bottom the submarine is
controlled by a series of complex
joysticks that are a lot more difficult
to under
stand than any ps3 controller once
they'd lowered the I in the seat webcam
to the bottom of the ocean it had to
attach the data cable to the network
that they'd installed previously after
carefully untying the thin rope that
held the data cable in place the team
used the submarines robotic arm to pull
at the data cable at few dozen meters to
the network hub the installation of the
world's first deepwater webcam was a
rousing success
Edie Widder one of the scientists called
an extremely rare experience noting that
Murphy of Murphy's Law obviously took
the day off